yeah and uh okay well okay exam and
tactics initiated yeah it's chaos
initiated because black is attacking the
White Queen and white did not move the
queen away White counter-attacked
against the black queen how if this
traits happen if both the Queens
disappear Magnus is simply going to be a
couple of forms up Magnus nodding his
head there slightly as well he thinks
he's got this one under control does
look that way so the Knight takes Knight
White's Queen Under Fire temporarily
black is a piece up but white has a
selection of pieces to take to recapture
yeah he can definitely do that and he's
done it and after Bishop taste Queen
Knight takes Queen check
takes Knights forced yeah until right
now Black's a piece up but now no longer
and look everything's getting hoovered
off all the captures gives a nasty check
that might have been a surprise from
Mama jar of look at mamajara's face it
was a surprise he resigns Magnus takes
the win wow and look at that reaction
from Magnus Carlsen I wasn't sure if he
was digging the music or digging the
victory